[موسيقى]
يا
لم تكن أمريكا رائعة أبدًا ، فقد تأسست
على الاغتصاب والقتل
لم يتغير شيء ، لذا فنحن نعد
ردنا الخاص
على هذه المواقف التي نتعامل
معها مع أشخاص يتعرضون لإطلاق النار كل يومين.
يطلقون النار على الناس يقتلون بعضهم البعض ،
السود يقتلون بعضهم البعض ،
لم يكن هناك أي طريقة أن
يجلس الناس فقط
ويسمحون بإطلاق النار على الأطفال من قبل
تطبيق القانون ، هذا البلد لا
يعمل بالنسبة لنا ، إنه لا يعمل بالنسبة لنا
هذا
لا يمكن أن يحدث في أمريكا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مايكل براون يقول اسمه ، الجميع
يريد أفضل لك يا رجل
فقط لا ينبغي أن يكون
هناك الكثير من الناس هنا يقاتلون من أجل
لقد
مرت ثلاث سنوات على وفاتك يا رجل ، نحن نفتقدك ،
نحبك ، أنت تهرب من ثورة
لهذا البلد بأكمله لهذا الرجل العالمي كله ،
كان الشيء عن مايك براون قبل
ذلك قد مرت عدة عقود منذ أن
كانت أمريكا قد شهدت انتفاضة كهذه
كما تعلم
ونحن نوعا ما فاتنا فرصتنا  نيتي
أشعر وكأنني في حالة فيرغسون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سيدي ، أنا أقدر لك الكفاح من أجل
حقوقنا سيدي ،
شكرًا لك على القتال من أجل حقوقنا
حقًا ، شكرًا
لك ، الدولة ليست لنا هذه الدولة
لا تعمل  بالنسبة لنا ، لا يعمل
بالنسبة لنا ،
لا يمكنك التحدث مع آلة هي
آلة لذلك لا يمكنك إجراء أي
محادثة
حقيقية حول الحياة الحقيقية والمشاعر وما
يمر
به الناس بآلة مع روبوت
يمكنك فقط تدميره  روبوت
يجب إزالته وإلغائه
لأنه عندما وضعوا الدستور
وكل هذا لم يكن مصنوعًا من أجل
[موسيقى]
لي
لم يرغب البيض في العيش بجوار
السود ولذا فقد أنشأ بعضًا  الضواحي
والمدن الصغيرة مثل ferguson
flores وهذه البلدات الصغيرة
كانت موجودة ، يمكنك معرفة ذلك من خلال الشقق
وهي تضم الكثير من المنازل ، لذا فهم يكدسون
الفقراء فقط فوق
بعضهم البعض
[موسيقى]
أنا أعيش في غطاء محرك السيارة  الذي يشبه على
الأرجح واحدًا من t
لا تأتي أقسى الأجزاء في شرطة الولاية في
كثير من الأحيان
يتم إطلاق النار على الأشخاص كل يومين ، حيث يتم إطلاق النار على الأطفال ،
ويقتلون بعضهم البعض. السود يقتلون
بعضهم البعض ويقتلون بعضهم البعض دائمًا كان لدي
شيء معهم
دائمًا
نفس القصة القديمة
[موسيقى]
أسود  لقد كان الناس دائمًا هدفًا ،
يقول دارين إنه كان رجلًا رائعًا ، كما تعلم
أنه كان جادًا ،
لقد أحب السود لدرجة أنه كان يحب شعبه
بما يكفي للتضحية ، لذلك بدأ في
تنظيم
الناس وبدأ في إنشاء منظمته الخاصة
لمحاولة محاربة بعض  هذه
الأشياء كان من
الممكن أن تكون هذه الأختام معروفة عالميًا بها
ولكن لم يكن مسموحًا للشرطة
بفقر [الموسيقى] يخلق الفقر جريمة في أي مكان
تتخلص فيه من
الفقر وتتخلص من الجريمة ، إنه أمر بسيط
أن الناس البسطاء فقراء هنا ،
هذا أحد  أدنى حد أدنى للأجور
في الدولة
مضايقات شرطية مستمرة أه
وباء المخدرات مثل الكثير من
العوامل المختلفة التي تتعامل
معها هنا
يستفيد التفوق الأبيض من تلك
العاصمة  تستفيد الحكومة المتشددة من ذلك
ونحن نجلس هنا ونتضور جوعاً ، لذا
ينظر الناس إلينا ويعتقدون
أنهم مجرد متوحشين أو حيوانات
أو أنهم لا يريدون أن يفعلوا ما
هو أفضل لا يعني ذلك أنه ليس لدينا
فرصة  للقيام بعمل أفضل
أه هل من الآمن الذهاب هنا والفيلم
يعتمد على إيمانك بأن الله قد فعل ،
أليس كذلك يمكن أن يحدث شيء سيء
لنا هنا
احتمال أكيد
ليس هناك ضمانات في الحياة هل هناك
منازل مهجورة في سانت لويس أكثر من أي مدينة أخرى  في أمريكا ،
الناس بحجمها مع أطفال يعرفون
أنهم ينتقلون إلى المقاطعة وينتقلون إلى
الضواحي من
أجل مدارس أفضل ولشوارع أكثر أمانًا
وكل هذا النوع من الأشياء ،
ما الأمر يا رجل كنت أبحث عنك ،
هذا ليس الماء كيف أنت  فعل
ذلك سيبقيك لائقًا
بالتأكيد ، فأنا أحب ذلك
سيبقيك لائقًا ،
فقط احصل على فرقعةك ، أعني
الحصول على اثنين ، حسنًا ، لقد حصلنا على
أشياء أخرى فقط احصل على
شريحتين وساندويتشين نعم ، آسف أنا آسف يا
أخي ها أنت ذا  قس بلدي
هذا ري  إنه
رجل نبيل جيد جدًا وأنا أحترم
كل ما يقوله وأحاول أن أعيش
وفقًا لما يقوله.
عندما تخرج إلى هنا ،
يكون هذا النوع من هذا النوع مع
الإخوة ، يسعدني حقًا رؤيته
مرحباً يونيو
[موسيقى]
يونيو
أعتقد أن أي شيء يحدث في
حياة الشخص ليس عشوائيًا
لأنه هناك
التصميم الإلهي وراء ذلك ،
عمدت شابًا كنت أعتني بكنيسة في ويبستر جروف ميسوري وعمدته في الرابعة عشرة من عمري ، ودفنته في السابعة عشرة.
بدأ الله يتحدث معي عن
العنف ، ثم
دفنت شابة شابة منجاة
أصيبت برصاصة في رأسها في
وضح النهار في حديقة
أمامها ، لذا استمرت هذه الأشياء في
الحدوث ، ظل هؤلاء الشباب
يموتون الذين كانوا في مجال
التأثير وأنا أكون  أحب أن الله كان يتحدث
معي عن النزول إلى الشوارع بعد
ذلك وقررت أنه من
المنطقي بالنسبة لي أن أخرج
حيث يوجد العنف
وأتفاعل وأشترك بأفضل طريقة
ممكنة وهذا ما نعتقده شخصًا واحدًا
في كل مرة
شارع واحد في كل مرة حي واحد
الآن بدأ الناس يقتلون بعضهم البعض ، لذلك
بعد وفاة مايك براون ،
تم إطلاق النار على المزيد من الناس وتم
سرقة المزيد
والمزيد من الناس هذا الصباح ليس باسم حركة
أو فيلم أو مال سيأتي إليك
اسم مايك مايك
لامار المصارعة ريتشارد باركر
مايكل لي مارشال المصارعة واين
ويلارد المصارعة
لافونتاي المصارعة الجنة والاستبداد الكاثوليكي الهندي
كروفورد المصارعة
المتأنق الأبيض لقد تم إعدامه كان
معلقًا حول الأطفال السود
وهكذا في أمريكا إذا  أنت تتسكع
حولك ، يعاملونك كما لو
في ذلك اليوم ، لقد تلقى معاملة
السود
أم
من تحمي من تخدمك
[تصفيق]
إذا لم نعيد أغراضنا
عيسى هاموند نريد من وزارة
العدل
محامي دائرة القديس لويس ومجلس الرقابة
المدني
للتحقيق في هذا ،
هناك الكثير من الأشياء الخاطئة
في هذه القضية ، أنا فقط أحاول الكفاح من
أجل العدالة من أجل أموالي ليس فقط من أجل
ابني  قتل الجميع
في المحكمة اليوم ، هناك ضابط
شرطة سابق ضابط شرطة يُدعى جيسون ستوكتون
جيسون
ستوكلي وهو مستعد لقتل من الدرجة الأولى
يخرج ستوكلي ويطلق أربع طلقات
بمسدس
مما أسفر عن مقتل سميث ستوكلي مرتين وعاد
إلى سيارة الشرطة لإسقاطه  من بندقية غير مستخدمة
وللتنقيب في حقيبة من القماش الخشن
، سمع سمع يقول أثناء
المطاردة
أنه سيقتل سميث
ولكني أعتقد أنه في نهاية اليوم
لن يتم اتهامه ،
سوف يسمحون له بالسير كما هم  دع
الجميع يمشي
هذا الرجل فقد حياته من أجل لا شيء
وهذا هو السبب في أننا هنا فقد حياته من
أجل لا شيء نحن بحاجة إلى العدالة نحن هنا من
أجل العدالة
ولهذا السبب تسلحنا  تأكد
من عدم
حدوث ذلك ، أعتقد أن الثورة الحقيقية
قد تحدث قريبًا ،
وأعتقد أن ذلك سيحدث في وقت أقرب من
انتفاضة أخرى في فيرجسون ،
أعتقد أنها ستبدو
وكأن الكثير من الناس
يموتون.  سوف يكون هناك الكثير من
الرصاص
ولكن بالنسبة لبعض الناس في هذا البلد كان
هذا دائمًا واقعًا
يموت بالرصاص إذا قاتلنا بطريقة حقيقية
وراء اللافتات في الشوارع ، ثم
نعم سيتغير
[تصفيق]
من تخدم
[موسيقى]
أنت تعرف أنني لا أرى سيارته ، لذا لا أعرف
أنني لا أعرف أين أتركها بعد الآن ،
فهو يعاني من الإدمان.
بضع كتل من هنا
نستمر في القدوم باستمرار وفي الوقت المناسب
نكون قادرين على بناء
ثقة حقيقية ولدينا علاقات حقيقية
معظم الناس هنا ليسوا أشخاصًا سيئين
ليسوا على الإطلاق ولا على الإطلاق طوال
الليل ، لقد كنا نوعًا ما  حذر
من القدوم إلى
هنا والمشي
بهذه الطريقة  في الليلة الماضية ، كنا جالسين
هنا مستريحيين ،
وأعتقد أن هذه السيارة ذات الأبواب الأربعة المظلمة ، وأعتقد أن
شيفروليه التي سحبت النوافذ كانت
بالفعل
مظلمة للغاية ، وقد توقفوا
علينا
ببطء شديد وكنت
متأكدًا من أننا في تلك الليلة
سنحصل على  أطلقوا النار
على الكثير من عمليات إطلاق النار هذه
الأيام حيث كان الناس
يتجولون ويطلقون النار على مكان آمن من السيارات ،
ما الأمر الآن ،
كل الأشخاص المناسبين ، لا ، لقد فعلنا
هذا منذ عامين ، والآن
يأتي الرجل إلى هنا للصلاة من أجل الناس
يمرون شطائرنا  قدم لنا الماء ،
شكرًا لك ، شكرًا لك ، شكرًا لك ،
بارك الله فيك ، شكرًا لك ،
حسنًا ، حسنًا ،
إنها منطقة أخرى خطيرة جدًا
[موسيقى]
لذلك لا أعرف حقًا ما أتوقعه
لمجرد أن أكون صادقًا معك ،
والآن هذه الهليكوبتر موجودة  هي مروحية تابعة للشرطة
نسميها طائر غيتو يبحثون
عن شخص
ما لدينا آه ما نسميه تقسيم ديل مار
حيث
يتم وضع خط أحمر على جزء واحد شمال ديل مار
وإهماله ، يتم إساءة استخدامه عن طريق الإهمال
والجانب الآخر الذي تعرفه  تحصل على
جميع الخدمات وجميع الفرص
التي
يتمتع بها معظم الأمريكيين البيض ، ربما كان
أكثر الأوقات رعباً
في الشهر الأول الذي بدأنا فيه
المشي وخرج هذا الشاب من
مبنى بمسدس يلعنني ويطلق
علي جميع أنواع الواشي وكل
شيء  طلبت من المجموعة المضي
قدمًا لأن
إحدى القواعد هي أنه إذا أصيب أي شخص
بالرصاص ، فيجب أن تكون
عدة طلقات نارية في وقت متأخر من
صباح يوم الأربعاء في 5400 من طريق ملوك الجنوب
السريع ،
تم إطلاق النار على أحد المشتبه بهم وقتل على يد
ضباط سوات في
يونيو  7
2017 تلقيت مكالمة هاتفية من والدي في حوالي
54 تفيد بأن ابني قد
مات بسبب قتله رجال الشرطة ،
قال والدي إن ابني ركض
إلى غرفته
وقال إن الجد ينزل على الأرض ويبقى على
الأرض أن
شخصًا ما يحاول اقتحام غرفتي
سأل الأب من الذي أطلق
النار وقال ابني لا أعرف جدي
أحبك مشى بضع خطوات
داخل غرفة الطعام وقال من فضلك لا
تطلق النار من
فضلك لا تطلق النار ثم
قتلوا ابني  مرحبًا ، بدأوا
في الاستمرار في إطلاق النار عليهم ،
لقد كان الرجل مجرد رجل روح رائع ، لقد
كان قويًا جدًا كما
لو كان على علاقة بنا جميعًا
كما تعلمون مثل
شقيقنا وتحدثنا عن أشياء تتجاوز أه
فقط مجرد
الاحتجاج و وأنت تعرف
الشرطة  وحشية وكان لديه الكثير من
التعاطف والكثير من القلب والكثير
من الرغبات للقيام
بأشياء أعظم مما تعلم ، آه فقط
دافع عن شعبه
ويدافع عن شعبه
ويجمعهم معًا مما يجعلنا جميعًا
نتحد
ونبني أعظم.  الحلم
وفقًا لتشريح الجثة ، تم إطلاق النار
عليه وتم حرقه ،
أعتقد بالتأكيد أن أكثر من عدد
كافٍ من المنظمات وأكثر من عدد
كافٍ من الناس
لديهم أكثر من دوافع كافية لما
حدث أثناء الأختام ،
إنها قائمة نتائج ، إنها قائمة استهداف
بأسماء وأختام  كان مدرجًا في قائمة النتائج ، كان لدي
العديد من الأشخاص الآخرين
الذين شاركوا في هذه الحركة ، وكان
الاسم في قائمة النتائج هذه ،
نتلقى تهديدات يومية من مجموعة kkk
وغيرها من الجماعات المتطرفة البيضاء  نحصل على
تهديدات من
مسؤولي الحكومة المكلفين بإنفاذ القانون في الشرطة ،
وعلينا أيضًا أن نتعامل مع نفس
القمع هنا في أحيائنا
لأننا أتينا من الشوارع التي تعاملنا
معها مع المنافسين
، وهذا سبب وجوب الركوب على هذا النحو ،
إنه سبب  العقل
وإيمانه المقدس ، دعنا
نعلن الآن بإخلاص وإحترام
أنني أؤمن بالله الأب القدير ،
صانع السماء والأرض
، وفي المسيح يسوع ابنه الوحيد
ولد سيدنا من قبل الشبح المقدس
المولود من مريم العذراء الذي عانى
بونتيوس
بيلاطس  مصلوبًا ودفن في اليوم الثالث
وقام من
الموت وصعد إلى الجنة وجلس
عن يمين الله الأب
[موسيقى]
القدير نشكرك الآن يا رب على هؤلاء الأشخاص
الذين نلتقي بهم ونحن نسير في الشوارع
ليلًا نصلي
الله باسم المسيح الذي تراه أحيانًا
في تلك الشوارع ،
أريد فقط أن أصرخ وأقول توقف عن
تعاطي المخدرات ، توقف عن
إطلاق النار على بعضكما البعض ، توقف عن الشرب ، أنت
تدمر حياتك ، أريد أن أقول ذلك
باركوا الجياع والأذى في
كل مكان ،
باركوا هذه الأمة باسم يسوع ،
أنا فقط أضع كلمة أنني
أقاتل من أجل ابني ،
أريد إجابات ولن أتوقف
حتى أحصل عليها ،
أريد الشخص الذي  هل أريد
إجابات
لماذا جاءوا وقتلوا ابني
بالطريقة التي فعلوها من
المفترض أن يحمونا لكنهم يقتلوننا
[موسيقى]
إنهم يقتلوننا
كانت حقيقة أننا لا نستطيع القيادة
في  في الشارع دون التعرض للمضايقات ،
كانت حقيقة أننا لا نستطيع إطعام أنفسنا
لأن هذه صحراء طعام ،
فلا توجد أموال تأتي إلى المدارس ،
ولا
توجد مواد لا يستطيع هؤلاء الأطفال حتى
أخذ الكتب إلى المنزل لأداء واجباتهم المدرسية ، إنها ليست
كتبًا كافية لهم  اصطحب الكتب
إلى المنزل لأداء واجباتنا المدرسية ،
لا يمكننا الحصول على وظيفة لأننا سود
لأن هذا البلد مبني على
قمع السود والألم الأسود ،
وهذا ما جعل الناس يقولون أنك تعرف
ما الذي سئمناه من هذا ،
نريد حريتنا ونحن  نريدها الآن
ولا نطلب
منك [موسيقى] نجاح باهر [موسيقى]